well the only one that we discussed in
this class was Prudence right and those
are all found in
book book six and I
personally think that Aristotle's
account of the intellectual
virtues um he numbers five of them right
so we have wisdom as Sophia we have
practical wisdom as uh f bis we have um
uh craft or art or um whatever we want
to call Tech skill uh we have uh it's
often translated as science or knowledge
epist and then we have this thing that's
kind of weird in a morph is called noose
right which seems to do a couple
different functions and it's often
translated as intellect but that's
that's not an adequate translation and I
kind of think that Aristotle's treatment
of the these in the nicam mcain ethics
it helps out with some things that Plato
raised as as real
problems but I don't think that it's
anywhere near an adequate account and
even if we start you know adding in
things coming from other
works um we're not you know you could
say this that that the Aristotelian
account of the intellectual virtues and
how it is that we know things and his
epist techology is underdeveloped you
know and I and I think what we see is
that later authors who are aristotelians
will try to preserve as much as they can
of his his
structure and then they'll expand on it
because you know some of the stuff is
obviously um too too broad but when I
said that um what he's doing is at least
better than what Plato is doing Plato is
is constantly asking asking us about
knowledge right and you get the idea
that he sets the bar too high for what
counts as knowledge like you don't know
virtue for example in the Mino if you
can't teach it successfully to other
people and teaching it successfully
means making them be virtuous people so
Pericles the great Athenian uh Statesman
presumably as a man of virtue but he
could his sons turn out to be bad right
and even Socrates right his kids turned
out to be you know kind of mediocre
right so if Socrates knew anything
presumably um he would have made his
kids good and you could say well he died
you know when they were young too bad
you know he would have laid down a good
foundation instead what he did is he was
going out and talking with all of his
friends all the time again staying away
from home right um so Aristotle is
saying listen there's different kinds of
knowledge or the way that he actually
puts it in the intellectual
virtues is there are different
excellences of mind that allow us to
attain truth and so truth looks
different in a
theoretical uh framework than it does in
a practical or productive framework so
you know the doctor who can successfully
heal you who has a a you know a
definitely a tech name and perhaps an
epist um they don't need to know
everything about medicine in order to
heal you properly they just need to be
able to like do the things that work for
the most case and the Potter doesn't
have to be a chemist to be able to glaze
their pots well and and fire them you
know and produce beautiful artifacts
that we can we can use reliably so
Aristotle is kind of you know reut Plato
and
saying you don't you know you science or
or knowledge doesn't have to be this
thing that's way the hell up here and
nobody actually has it that's actually
going to lead to a kind of skepticism
instead what we want to do is
distinguish different ways of knowing so
knowing how to respond
appropriately in the workplace when your
colleague breaks down in tears because
something bad happened to them how to
respond you know compassionately justly
all that that doesn't require like a
textbook knowledge of human psychology
that would be epistem that you figured
out and have gotten completely right and
and I think that's that's a good side to
it but I think that his his treatment of
the intellectual virtues like I said is
a bit under underdeveloped
underdetermined and
um so you know it can be useful to talk
about
um the different modes of knowing but I
don't think we want to stick with
Aristotle on
that